and joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is the man whose life will be
chronicled in the first episode of icons
on epics
saturday night at nine eastern time pro
football hall of famer none other than
brett favre back here on the rich
housing show how you doing brett
i'm doing good rich how about yourself
hanging in there man so um
your life has been chronicled a million
times in documentaries
this one feels a little bit different
there's tons of photographs from your
from your high school years and your
early years have you gotten a chance to
to see the hour yet brett
um
i've seen bits and pieces
you know some of those pictures i
haven't seen in my goodness uh
you know over 20 or 30 years and you
know it's
as if i need any help
knowing how old i am and how quickly it
goes by you know the older you get the
faster it goes but it's
it's a it's a pleasant reflection to
back over not only my pro career but
dating back to the grade school well i
mean we just showed a picture of you
taking a knee in a number 10 jersey uh i
mean if you if you who was number 10 for
just you just got issued that is that a
high school picture of you running
around yeah there it is number two uh
yeah i was uh
i was number 10 until i got to southern
miss uh that was my favorite number uh
and
you know
i got southern miss reggie collier
who was a great player southern miss
had number 10 and i asked the equipment
manager if i could have number 10 he
said you have four
or no jersey at all and i said i'll take
four
i didn't have much bargaining power back
then so that's how you got number four
in your career that's exactly how i got
number four
oh it's amazing how that happens then of
course so you asked for number four
everywhere you went after that yeah
pretty much yeah i mean i i figured you
know there wasn't many number fours uh
before me that had had really done the
number
uh very proud so i said hey
why not be the first
what do you think of when you're
referred to as an icon
brett
you know i i sort of
um
inside i kind of chuckle you know i i
and i've said this so many times
where i came from
uh the story and i know there's other
guys that could that have stories as
well that that are just as uh
compelling or or
uh
you know like you got to be kidding me
type stories but you know i ran
a lot of kids today don't even know for
a kid who ran the wishbone and the wing
t
and never threw it
you know i had a pretty doggone good
career you know who they ever thunk it
back then you know that was my dream
to become not an icon but to become a
pro football player and and
to to far exceed the expectations and
the hopes that i had as a young kid
is
is uh you know i i can't i can't tell
you how grateful and thankful i am for
the opportunity and i'm just glad that i
made the most of it brett favre here on
the rich eisen show again icons which i
am honored to be narrating along with
epics and nfl films an hour-long
documentary on folks
like jerry rice and emmett smith and my
current guest brett favre debuting
saturday night 9 eastern time on epics
right here on the rich eisen show brett
what do you think is going through tom
brady's mind right now as he is a couple
of days removed from being in foxborough
as an opponent what was going through
your mind i would think
you know i would think
tom is probably
maybe not so much today but uh you know
come saturday evening saturday night
certainly sunday morning
um as he makes that bus ride to foxworth
as an opponent for the first time
um it will be as if
it's his first start you know back when
he was a patriot um i mean it has that
type of feel to it that this
is hard to explain because only a few
guys have been able to do it but it's a
it's a
nervous
excited
um
you know like
almost wondering how you're going to be
received by the fans
which i don't think that'll be
that's a no-brainer i think he'll be
well received but i mean he he wants to
go in there not that he has anything to
prove to his team his former team or to
the former management but you know he
wants to play his best and you know tom
normally does play his best week in week
out
so i
i envision
another tom brady type day
but
but you know with the joy
and and enthusiasm like he like he was
when he first got when drew bledsoe got
hurt he came in
well i mean you on the night of november
1st 2009 when you returned to lambeau
for the first time as you just kind of
pointed out it was a whole
different ball of wax from the fact that
you know uh you didn't know how you were
gonna be received you were also going
against aaron rodgers this time it's mac
jones for him and i don't think patriots
fans are gonna have a similar reaction
to his appearances maybe some packers
fans had to you but i mean what was that
like for you that night when you
strolled out onto lambeau field and you
weren't wearing the g on the side of
your helmet i mean for him i i still
even imagine despite winning the super
bowl for the [ __ ] years it'll be a
bizarre experience
for him yeah you know i i um i had a
you know deep down i had a feeling that
you know there would be a lot of booze
um so i i i wasn't really overwhelmed
with the
the reception i got
i was almost
um flattered because it was the loudest
i'd ever heard
lambo in regards to a visiting team or a
visiting player and so i took great
pride and was sort of honored by that
but much like when my father passed away
there was enormous pressure that i
i had internally
to perform at i
at a level that you know i even i didn't
know if i could perform at and i of
course i wanted to win that was most
important but i knew
in order to do that i had to play well
and i played well pre several weeks
before
against the the packers in minnesota
but this was a different
totally different
you know deal playing in in lambeau
so
the pressure was on to perform at at the
highest level and and that was you know
i think back to i had butterflies like
no other uh in that game well you had
four touchdowns in that game just like
the the game that you with your dad uh
after it passed on that monday i mean so
how does tom how would you counsel tom i
know he's he's been there and done that
but on on focusing with all the circus
and the level of expectations i don't
think
tom needs any advice from me or anyone
else i mean he he obviously has played
in big games lots of big games playoffs
super bowls
this is a first for him obviously
um and he'll
you know his experience and his his
demeanor will will will be fine i you
know i this is not a really
good patriots team i'm not saying that
they can't beat tampa but
um
you know i think the one thing that you
can't do and i'm sure he knows this is
you can't
you you just can't force the issue you
just gotta you you want it you want to
play well you want to play lights out
you want to play better than you've ever
played before but you got to let it come
to you
and it will uh they're i think they're
they're just way too good a team
uh
to to lay an egg in this one yeah i mean
he it's again he how badly did you want
to win that night
in in fact i don't know if there was
ever a game that i wanted to win of
course i wanted to win a super bowl
um
you know
as much as any game i ever played in but
i i can't say that
beating the packers was not
as as equal if not more uh of a priority
to me
is that a way that you really wanted to
beat their ass is that what you were
you're basically saying to me brad yeah
yeah how could you not want to prove to
your old team now again the
circumstances the situation was a little
bit different right uh with with my deal
as opposed to tom
um
but you know i had the i i felt like you
know i was too good
to play against the packers
and not good enough to play for them
that's kind of the feeling i got from
management at the time and so how could
you not want to prove that
they made a mistake
brett favre here on the rich eisen show
and advance again of icons
um that he will be featured as the debut
episode one-hour documentary i'm
narrating nfl films and epics putting
together right here on the rich eisen
show uh
how do you think the um
story with aaron rodgers is gonna end
brett
what do you think how do you think that
ends
you know i was surprised by the whole
deal this past offseason i you know i
they have they got a good thing going
and they get still got a good thing
going you know they played back really
poorly in the first game
but they're playing now like you would
expect
and i don't see that you know other than
really aaron and his age and i don't see
any decline in his play if anything he's
better
there are good young i i you know i just
don't know if this
if his chances to win the super bowl go
up going anywhere else
you know i so
i just find it hard to believe that um
that he would go anywhere else and
management would let him go anywhere
else nor would he
choose to go anywhere else i i assume
they got everything resolved so i
i see him finishing his career in green
bay now
will he play as long as tom brady i mean
his age is his age but he doesn't he
plays as if he's 25.
well i he was on a couple weeks ago on
this show brett favre and uh i asked him
what had changed between the off-season
and then the day that he came in that
make him want to come in and end all of
this even though as i said i kept
referring to him as being back with
green bay even though he technically
never left but
and he said the only thing that had
changed was trust and hope those are the
words i wrote them down here in this
book as he wrote it down because i'm a
professional i write things down and he
said uh trust nope it's a beautiful
thing
or it can lead to despair and
frustration is what he said and right
now he's got trust and hope and i
thought to myself that that's all it is
i mean
why won't the packers just essentially
say well we're sticking to our plan
jordan love we drafted him even though i
think that would be kind of crazy
so i don't i don't know how it ends is
what i'm saying because well
honestly i don't either you know i i
think i'm
uh
maybe assuming too much even though
um they got a good thing going you know
i i don't think jordan love is the issue
really i think it's more
retaining players are bringing players
back that
he felt comfortable with uh obviously
randall cobb is his tops on that list
but
you know it's going to be interesting to
see if they retain the players that
he hopes that they
that he would that they retained
devante adams
you may be a lineman maybe maybe it may
be a guy you really don't know much
about but to him
you know is vital to their success um
it's going to be it's going to be
interesting to see
if management
yields to
to his demands
that would be sort of a first
if it happens
brett favre here on the rich eisen show
and i guess lastly it's a fascinating
matchup for the packers this weekend
with big ben coming in and the whole
concept of you know wanting to make sure
that you're not sticking with a
quarterback who's got diminishing
returns out of the blue and the first
three weeks for big ben he has not
looked good at all don't know if it's
the offense if it's his physical
abilities when did you first realize
brett that maybe
your
physical abilities that you were seeing
the returns diminish when when did that
first happen for the guy who was the
iron man of football you know uh
my last year as a packer was my best
year statistically speaking we had a
great year we almost got to the super
bowl but but we did
the previous year
was uh just an okay year
and i i really felt like that year
it was uh
i won't say obvious but sort of obvious
if that makes sense that to me
that i didn't you know my game was
different than aaron my game was
different than tom brady um
my relied on you know i was kind of
uncharacteristically uh you know a a
pocket quarterback you know so
i i i could drop back in and
my footwork would look okay and i would
step in the pros i would do that uh
you know fair amount but a lot of my
game was i felt pressure i escaped made
plays on them on the move
left right it didn't matter
my dodge ability if you will
and i didn't feel like that i in the
15th year as a packer that
i felt like the things that i used to
escape from
i didn't escape from as much
i didn't react as much to a you know a
blind side you know you can feel
something you
people say he's got a sixth sense
um i still had it but sometimes i would
tell myself duck
and i would get hit and then i would
react to it
and not all the time
but i just felt like um
in year 15 which was my 16th year
in the league
i noticed my arm strength felt great and
uh
once i had bicep surgery after i left
jets it felt tremendous
and you know i went on minnesota and
played exceptionally well
maybe the best i've ever played
but
i i you know i still even in that year
and with the jets
things just kind of lingered injuries
lingered new things popped up
and um along with the
the mobility
shift i guess if you will uh um
i yeah i started sensing it around year
15. can you see it when you see it in a
current quarterback like even if it's
big ben can you if watching it you could
say okay that that looks like the stuff
that i was going through you know what i
see more than anything and not
necessarily with big ben but just in
general just thinking back over the
years and and just you know knowing what
i know now
i i i tend to see the first thing that
goes is a mental
part of it where you don't necessarily
believe for whatever reason you can't
make that throw you can't escape
you know um
i can almost see it in the faces of
players uh like you know maybe my times
is drawing closer to the end
and i you know obviously i'm not right
all the time but but i think big ben has
has been
exceptionally great for a long time and
and very
sneaky
uh from a mobility standpoint you know
he can he can
i mean
slither out of just about anything
and that that starts diminishing a
little bit and how
how that
transition goes i mean can you
transition into a non-escape quarterback
so almost like a
bewildered
look on a guy's face if that makes sense
um it sure does brett um thanks for the
call always appreciate catching up with
you and i look forward to seeing the
full icons on on epic saturday night
you'll be welcome hey it's always fun
talking with you rich always fun talking
on right back at you that's brett favre
right here and uh you know i saw you in
that serious xm commercial how many
takes in the bathtub for you and that's
look one take guy but they they wanted
about 50 different lines
so we went through a lot of bubbles
okay
all right
kind of like you know uh very nice
temperature so they did they warm it up
for you a few times like oh yeah i was
sweating bullets
hey these things happen in retirement
you know what i'm saying they do take
care of yourself brett favre thanks for
the call yeah it's brett favre of pro
football hall of famer again catch icons
on epochs saturday night 9 eastern time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here